hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
la entrevista en france son 24 en esta
oportunidad vamos a ir a españa y lo
haremos para hablar sobre las violencias
y los crímenes de odio hacia las
personas lgtb de más crímenes que no son
nada nuevo lamentablemente pero un hecho
en particular volvió a traer a la
superficie las agresiones
lg betis fóbicas en este país europeos
estamos hablando del asesinato del joven
samuel louis en una brutal golpiza por
parte de un grupo de personas como odia
antes que lo mataron mientras le
gritaban a el pasado 3 de julio
en la ciudad de la coruña en españa si
bien el crimen de samuel no es en
absoluto el único episodio de violencia
como odia antes que sucede en españa en
los últimos tiempos el asesinato provocó
que miles de personas salieran a las
calles de varios países a lo largo del
mundo para rechazar ese y otros ataques
recientes hacia personas lg gt y kumasi
para dialogar sobre este tema saludamos
ya mismo a elisabeth duval ella es
escritora y filósofa autora de varios
libros como después de los trans
y también excepción elisabeth uvas
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
france24
muchas gracias a vosotros es un placer
estar aquí
bueno elisabeth a samuel lamentablemente
lo mataron en un país que es considerado
vanguardista en muchos aspectos sobre
todo en términos de inclusión no el eje
de españa fue de hecho el tercer país de
todo el mundo en aprobar por ejemplo el
matrimonio igualitario hay al menos
desde el exterior una imagen de una
españa inclusiva diversa amigable diría
yo de alguna manera estábamos
equivocados elisabeth
yo creo que el hecho de que se hayan
aprobado leyes que vayan a favor del
colectivo lgtb de manera general no está
reñido con que la violencia siga
presente y con que sigan pudiendo
existir crímenes de odio como aquel del
cual ha sido víctima samuel es decir
aunque se aprueben leyes que permitan el
matrimonio igualitario o se apruebe una
ley trans xornal y contra electiva y
fobia muchas veces tanto lo legal como
lo social van por carriles o velocidades
separadas con lo cual simplemente lo que
este senado nos dice es que hay todavía
mucho por hacer aunque aparentemente en
españa y yo creo que lo es sea un país
los de tolerante sigue habiendo personas
que evidentemente no lo son y que son
capaces de cometer un realidad es así
ahora otra pregunta que surge elisabeth
es si estamos ante un aumento de lo que
son las agresiones hacia personas lgtb
de iq o ahora se están denunciando y
visibilizando más quizás
si yo justamente sería seria precavida a
la hora de señalar que se trate como tal
de un aumento precisamente porque igual
que ocurre en los casos de violencia de
género en aquellos países que tienen una
cultura o fomentan digamos socialmente
mayor feminismo mayor conciencia de
estas cuestiones hay una mayor cantidad
de gente que denuncia no es la primera
vez en españa que sucede algo así
sucedido con una mujer trans semanas son
y en barcelona hace en 20 años ha
sucedido varias veces tipo de palizas lo
que sucede es que normalmente cuando
dónde una paliza pues deja tve no acá
hay un asesinato no acabe en algo tan
brutal y es una respuesta excepcional
desde luego pero que no significa que el
clima necesariamente en los últimos años
haya ido a peor
haremos se dice que un poco de contexto
social político y también cultural que
se está viviendo en la actualidad en
españa hay un avance de la derecha no en
instituciones del país con discursos
bastante homo de antes como tiene por
ejemplo el partido político box no este
clima social crees que legítima de
alguna manera este tipo de crímenes o
quizás mejor dicho allana quizás el
terreno para que los asesinos el gti
fóbico salgan a matar básicamente
yo creo que lo más preocupante no es
solamente o no es particularmente la
presencia de un partido como box de un
partido como de extrema derecha en las
instituciones sino el hecho de que ese
partido se había legitimado reforzado de
que ese partido con él por parte de la
derecha tradicional española que es el
partido popular es decir si existiera
algo así como existe en francia que es
un cordón sanitario de no hacer acuerdos
de no participar de aquellos acuerdos
los que participan extrema derecha quizá
la situación no sería con ellos la
actualidad y sin embargo en principales
capitales de provincia o la capital de
españa en madrid el partido popular
gobierna con el apoyo de box y ha
permitido que ese apoyo de box marque
cuáles son sus políticas y ha adaptado
su discurso para acercarse más a ellos y
eso es lo realmente peligroso que esté
asumiendo la derecha tradicional
el discurso de esa extrema derecha
radical
ahora en este tipo de casos exactamente
es muy interesante esto que está
planteando elizabeth ahora quisiera
abordar otro punto porque junto a un
grupo de artistas escritoras también
académicas de españa ha suscrito el
manifiesto que se denomina contra la
lgtbfobia cambiarlo todo para ser más
libres y bueno uno de los planteos
principales no que allí plantean es el
rechazo a lo que son las políticas de
venganza y de prisión para los agresores
ante las agresiones lg o diantes ustedes
están planteando ni venganza ni castigo
algo muy interesante podría desarrollar
esta idea para nuestra audiencia
claro no se trata de que no haya algún
tipo de justicia sino que es más bien
remarcar que si hay un momento el fbi
éste no puede estar concentrado
solamente en medidas punitivas y medias
positivistas sino que creo que en todos
los casos incluso en estos hay que
pensar en la justicia como algo que sea
capaz de cierta reinserción reinserción
social como algo que tenga un objetivo
que no sea solamente el de vigilar y
castigar a los ciudadanos y este precio
importante igual que es importante que
en un momento en el cual en españa desde
hace unos años el movimiento feminista
estado muy concentrado en la lucha
contra violencia de género contra
violaciones que ese movimiento feminista
por ejemplo no derive simplemente en una
voluntad de castigo de incrementar las
penas de prisión porque creo que lo que
buscamos es una transformación social
mucho más radical esa transformación
cultural no es más radical que vaya
realmente a lo que es la raíz del
problema y que no vaya simplemente a
castigar a cuáles son sus consecuencias
no es simplemente poniendo en prisión a
aquellos que han cometido estas
velocidades que se va a acabar la
energética y fobia lo que se va a acabar
el machismo
hacer una serie de políticas mucho más
profundas ahora estoy pensando pero es
también importante que el movimiento
feminista incluya a las personas trans
no porque hay un sector no del feminismo
que bastante excluyente respecto de las
personas trans
desde lo que es importante pero yo creo
que en los mismos tiempos también se ha
demostrado que por mucho que una parte
de ese sector quiera arrogarse la
actualidad del feminismo no deja de ser
una fracción no deja es una fracción
incluso a mis ojos minoritaria hay una
gran cantidad de feministas
particularmente en españa' que apoyan y
siempre han apoyado los desórdenes trans
y siempre han estado ahí yo creo que es
importante también que esa parte del
feminismo que el continuo con
mayoritaria se visibilice y hable porque
son dos luchas son dos momentos que
tienen que ir de la mano y que no pueden
ir por separado claro ahora cómo afecta
en elisabeth los medios de comunicación
a lo que es la lucha contra la lgtbfobia
porque ustedes en el manifiesto
advierten que muchísimos tratan a los
crímenes bajo una lógica del espectáculo
verdad y eso no colabora para nada
no solamente una lógica de espectáculos
una lógica incluso morbosa o en el caso
concretamente de samuel ruiz bajo una
lógica que negaba que hubiera podido ser
un asesinato homofóbico simplemente
porque decían que al no saber su
identidad sexual realmente cuando había
dicho no podía decirse que eso fuera
porque él fuera gay cuando en el momento
de que asesinan a alguien adicto y
cuando están apaleando a alguien
varias personas le dan una paliza por
llamando de esta manera se trata también
de que se percibe de cierta manera otra
también de que nos atacan precisamente
por quiénes somos por cómo nos
manifestamos y es muy importante que los
medios no corran la irresponsabilidad de
mirar a otro lado y por ejemplo la labor
del país con la portada del país
semanal'
marcando claramente con la agenda
contraer y fobia aquí en españa ha sido
bastante importante y eso no quita que
desde otros medios en medios
conservadores sobre todo hayamos
asistido a manifestaciones realmente
lamentables ahora es clave aquí
elisabeth lo que es la importancia de
llegar a un punto sin retorno en el que
no existan o sea las etiquetas ni se
hable ya de géneros es ahí donde se
acabará el odio hacia las personas lgtb
y crees que esto sucederá en algún
momento
creo que es bastante complicado por una
cuestión también de categorización
simplemente humana que dejemos de
construir taxonomías o que dejemos de
categorizar a la gente y creo que más
que intentar pensar en esa perspectiva
casi tópica relación con estas
cuestiones con estos delitos o crímenes
de odio lo que hay que atajar son
mentalidades mucho más concretas creo
que hay que construir una mayor
aceptación de la diversidad donde la
aceptación del otro de quien la hambre
sobre todo de quienes hay que fomentar
la cultura entre la población no creo
que ninguna población por aparentemente
conservadora que sea esté condenada de
antemano a tener este tipo de crímenes y
creo que es algo que podemos atajar el
cholo que es algo que es urgente que nos
ocupemos de ello la sociedad
absolutamente es sin lugar a dudas
urgente elisabeth bueno un poco hablaba
de esto que te voy a preguntar ahora a
continuación hablemos de algunas de las
consecuencias que tienen estos crímenes
porque en definitiva como decías estamos
ante asesinatos que se
porque hay alguien que no tolera que
otra persona sea determinar la manera
que sea como es y que lo sea además de
una manera evidente no clara sin
transformarse en algo que no es para ser
aceptada de alguna manera esto
tranquilamente puede generar que muchas
personas piensen bueno si yo soy como
soy me van a matar y ahí
elisabeth la existencia se transforma no
sé en una suerte de supervivencia puede
ser un calvario
he hecho yo creo que es muy cierto que
en el momento reciente en súbitamente
hemos visto a una persona se le vi
hablar de cómo tienen miedo o cómo
tienen miedo a presentarse tal y como ya
son en la calle y creo que el mensaje
que hay que mandar es el contrario en
todo sentido hay que transmitir el hecho
de que aunque esto puede suceder españa
sigue siendo una ciudad bastante abierta
es pueden seguir siendo los ciudades que
se pueden manifestar de forma
relativamente libre y por lo tanto creo
que más que nunca por más que algo tan
atroz haya sucedido ahí precisamente que
mostrarse de manera libre ante ante el
mundo y el mensaje que mandaría al poner
a efe-tv es ss no deben depender mucho
del ambiente y la seguridad que se tenga
y de los círculos alrededor que se
tengan pero es un mensaje de no tener
miedo ante la situación elisabeth dual
se ha acabado el tiempo seguiría
llegando con tigo muchísimo más te
agradezco muchísimo su presencia en la
entrevista de france 24
muchas gracias a vosotros uno por favor
a ti ya nuestra audiencia como siempre
les invitamos a continuar informándose
en el resto de nuestra programación y
también en france 24 punto com
[Música]